ils veulent il a côtoyé les plus grands
et ses vidéos font le tour du monde
depuis 2012 vince qui est aujourd'hui
l'inde et influençant les plus connus de
france avec plus d'un million d'abonnés
depuis 2010 est le youtuber a décidé de
lancer un nouveau projet dans les
yvelines en créant sa propre équipe de
football dans la région nantaise levine
sky fc l'objectif succession de raconter
des histoires sur trois idées etc et à
créer un club de foot c'est un petit peu
la suite logique pour quelqu'un que
j'aime bien le foot c'est à dire si on
pouvait pas créer un concept un
collectif avec des amis etc donc j'ai
proposé un peu des amis d'enfance des
gens je connaissais même des abonnés
aussi j'ai recruté si c'était chaud pour
le projet et c'est vous accédez en fait
c'est pour continuer toujours à raconter
une histoire sur youtube depuis 2019 le
club est affilié à la fédération
française de football la structure a
commencé en 6e division de district
évolue désormais en cinquième division
chaque rencontre est enregistré et
diffusé sur internet des milliers de
personnes suivent les aventures du club
une source de motivation pour les
joueurs mais également les adversaires
on nous entend beaucoup au tournant tous
les week-ends on nous croit privilégiée
mais pour nous on fait abstraction de ça
et est vraiment on joue au foot pour le
plaisir c'est pas du tout la même
échelle on a un peu comme paris où tout
le monde veut nous battre on existe kfc
forcément tout le monde veut nous battre
donc on n'est pas pareil en jeu précise
mais voilà c'était dans l'image quoi
aujourd'hui l'équipe senior est à la
troisième place du classement et vise la
montée en fin de saison une aventure
sportive que vince cas issus
principalement sur le bord du terrain
regardant ses joueurs le youtuber
président n'a joué que 45 minutes depuis
le début de la saison c'était compliqué
voire plusieurs casquettes d'être
président d'être de gérer la
communication de manager le club et
d'être joueur aussi en plus à leurs
côtés des jours très bon à mon poste qui
sont même plus fort que moi dans vos
dires une pas de même pas de débat là
dessus donc ça va après gestion ma
licence de joueur il l'idée c'est que je
sois plus dans les plans on va dire du
coach dont la saison après le tour là au
cas où si un produit vince cas espère
encore faire grandir ce club
l'influencera créer une académie cas
pour objectif d'encadrer des jeunes
footballeurs sur le plan sportif
scolaire et culturel pour les seniors
vince qui rêvent de les emmener un jour
en ligue 1